Hello, everyone.
My name is Dr.
Patel. I'm one of
the pediatricians
at Old Westbury.
I will be talking about
pediatric rheumatology
today, which I
know you guys get a
lecture on rheumatology
in general and a lot
of adult rheumatology,
but this will be
a little bit of a
pediatric aspect of it.
So let's get started.
Okay, so here are
the objectives. We're
going to talk about
just some basic
concepts, which I'm
sure you guys already
know, but it might
be a good refresher.
And then common pediatric
pathologies that
we're going to talk
about are all these
that are listed here.
The one I want you
guys to really focus
on that's different
than some of the
other ones are really
your juvenile idiopathic
arthritis or GIA.
And we'll go into
that pretty in depth.
Everything else is
sort of relatable
to the adult side
with just a couple
of nuances and
differences, which we
can talk about as
we go through them.
But GIA is what I want
you guys to focus on.
So I'm going to
start with a question
because I think
it helps us to
relate it to
something to make it a
little bit more
concrete, all this
information that I'm
about to give you.
So we'll start
with a question. A
three-year-old
male brought to the
clinic by his
mother for about two
months of swelling
in his knees.
He went to the urgent
care three months
ago for upper
respiratory infection.
It stops him from
running around as
much, and he also
felt warm the past
two weeks, especially
in the evenings.
He's also had
some red and pink
circles on his skin
during that time,
which then go
away on his own.
On exam, his conjunctiva
are pale bilaterally.
There's papable
cervical, inguinal,
and popatial lymph nodes
and lymphadenopathy.
His liver is three
centimeters below
the costal margin,
and his vitals include
a heart rate of 130
while it's calm.
So the question
is, if you get
blood work on
this patient, what
do you think it
would show? OK,
so multi-part
question, which is how
you should get used
to thinking about
questions, because when
you are taking your
board exams, this
is how they're going
to ask you that
they're going to ask
you in a higher order
question or second
order, third, third
order question.
So, for example,
you have to know in
this scenario, in
this little question
stem that you get
what the diagnosis is.
And then once you figure
out the diagnosis,
now it's asking you
if you got blood
work, what do you
think it would show?
Right. So enforces
two different ideas.
So you should
kind of get in the
mindset of
thinking like that.
All right. So every
anytime I approach a
problem, like a
question, I tend to in my
head just sort of
highlight the most
important things. And
on your exams, you can
use the highlight
button to also help you.
And that for me kind
of narrows it down
from all the other
details that are in the
question. So, for
example, for this for
this question, the age
is important. So he's
three years old. He's
had two months of
this swelling in his
knees on both sides.
He had a recent URI.
He isn't able to run
as much. There's some
activity limitation.
And he's he has also
felt warm for the past
two weeks, especially
the evenings. And then
these red and pink
circles that he's had,
which then go
away on exam.
He's had some
conjunctival pallor, which
we've seen, and the
cervical lymphadenopathy
and the kind of systemic
lymphadenopathy.
He also has some
hepatomegaly
and then a
tachycardia as well.
So and again, what
they're asking is
the blood work. OK,
so we're going to
keep that in our
in the back of our
minds as we go
through this lecture.
OK, let's start with
some just basic concepts.
So the truth is
that rheumatological
conditions can
mimic a lot
of different
other conditions.
So it's really
important to do a
good history and
physical to kind
of piece out
those components.
And then you will
get some autoimmune
markers, some
serological testing. You
can get some path
testing and then
some imaging. So all
that put together
is when you would
kind of diagnose
someone with a
rheumatological disease.
And then there's
some clues that might
help you determine
whether this is
rheumatologic in nature
or something else.
So some fevers that
kind of come and go,
arthritis. So
that means arthra,
which means joint,
and algaes, which
means pain. So
they come with
joint pain, but
also with arthritis.
So inflammation.
So itis is the
inflammation, right, of the
joint. So you not
only get joint pain,
but you also get
inflammation of the joint.
Timing. So usually
rheumatological
conditions present with
morning stiffness and
then it gets better
as you use it more.
Also, a lot of them
are accompanied by
rash and then weakness
and fatigue, sort
of systemic other
signs of inflammation.
Remember, it's
usually the duration
that will likely
clue you in that this
is something that's
been going on for
a longer period of
time than something
that might be acute
that you might want
to look at in one
kind of instance.
Going along with the
joint stiffness, you
can also have limited
range of motion,
pain with joint
motion. You
can have gait
disturbances.
Like I said, the
fevers and the fatigue
and weakness kind
of go together.
So that's all things
you want to think
about. Okay, what you
don't want to miss
in someone you
suspect might have a
rheumatological condition,
but you don't want
to miss this because
that can be very
detrimental to the
patient because the
treatments are very
different, right? Right.
So the things you
don't want to miss is
cancer, of course. So
ALL, neuroblastoma,
those can all mimic
some of these signs,
especially like
fever, joint like
joint pain,
overall weakness.
Some of the inflammatory
markers that
we'll see rashes.
Those are all things
that can also
present with cancer,
bone pain. Right.
Then you have things
like infections.
So viral diseases,
you don't
want to miss a
septic arthritis,
Lyme disease, which
can cause arthralgias
in the later
manifestations of Lyme.
Osteomyelitis, again,
bone pain, but now
with infection and
pus in the bone, which
can also present with
fever, rash, bone
pain, fatigue, things
like that, limitation
of range of motion.
and then some other
systemic kind of things
like metabolics or
thyroid disorders can
also cause weakness
fatigue chronic
pain disorders like
fibromyalgia depression
can also cause overall
kind of pain and
arthralgias without
arthritis's you can have
vasculitides that also
mimic it and we'll
talk about one of the
vasculitides that's
kind of characterized
in rheumatologic as
well in that bucket.
Orthopedic concerns,
so patellofemoral
syndrome, growing
pains, that can also
present with similar
symptoms. And then
autoimmune disorders
such as IBD can
also present with
fever, rash, some joint
pain, weakness, fatigue,
also accompanied
by some the GI
symptoms, of course.
Okay.
So next, I have
this, sorry.
Okay. Next, I have this
table that I really
liked that I got from
Nelson's Pediatrics.
It has all sort of some
basic characteristics
and then the different
pathologies that
are most common that
you'll probably see.
So lupus is this one,
um, JIA, which is
the one I told you
guys that is really
important is here. Um,
then things that kind of
mimic these symptoms
like leukemia, lymph,
um, sorry, Lyme
disease, rheumatoid, uh,
rheumatic fever, um, got
a, got a coxie me. Uh,
I can't talk today.
Um,
got a coxie me a
Kawasaki disease.
Those are all, um, things
that could present
with fever,
a rash, uh, joint
pain, things like that.
So this is a good kind
of summary of some
of them and then kind
of comparing them side
by side. So please go
through this if you
have some time, because
it just helps me and
my brain to kind of
organize these things.
Because in the question
stems, when they're
going to ask you,
they're going to ask
you some things that
will help you say,
okay, it's this versus
this other thing
that has similar kind
of findings, okay?
Okay,
so still going
along with the basic
concepts. For diagnosis,
you want to do a
complete physical
exam. So remember that
these rheumatological
conditions are
multi-system, which
means they involve more
than just one body
part, right? So you
want to do a very
thorough skin exam.
Oh, there we go. There
I am. You want to
do a very thorough
skin exam, scalp exam,
which could include
any like, you know,
alopecia or generalized
skin rashes.
You can find rashes
that spare nasolabial
folds, which mean
one thing versus
if they don't could
mean another thing.
Sometimes the
rashes around the
ears, the eyes,
lower extremities.
Remember we talked
about hair patterns.
You also want to
look at the nail
beds. Those are
super important. And
the way we do that
is we do nail fold
capillaryoscopy.
That's not easy to say.
And that usually shows
abnormalities in the
small capillaries in
the nail bed. So that's
what this picture on
the bottom left is
showing you, is that
this patient, the images
in A, B, and C show
abnormal vessel growth.
And what it should look
like is in panel D.
That's normal nail bed
capillaries, whereas
you see they're more
torturous, you're
more dilated, they're
more abnormal in their
shape in both B and
C. And you can see
them, if it's really
severe, you can see
them grossly, but the
little visualization
tool, the capillarioscopy,
really helps
you look at it even
closer. You'll see
they'll be branched or
bushy, and that's from
neovascularization
of those capillaries.
Okay. And this
whole panel, this
four panel is
from a 19-year-old
with juvenile
dermatomyositis.
So that's good.
All right. You
want to look at the
oropharynx because a
lot of these patients
will have ulcers.
So specifically,
the hard palate,
which is at the top
of your mouth, that
can have ulcers,
which can be
associated with lupus.
And this is a
picture of that
above the
capillary oscopy.
You can also get a lot
of mucositis in the
mouth. So mucositis
just means inflammation
of the mucosa. So
lips will be cracked.
they'll be um they'll
be bleeding inside is
very friable of the
the mouth it's painful
um you can also get
tmg tmj so um joint
instability and inflammation
which is specifically
associated with one
of the rheumatological
conditions but
that's also something
that you can check in
your physical exam you
want to check for
lymph nodes of force
lymphadenopathy um you
want to check the eyes.
So uveitis is very
commonly seen in a lot
of different rheumatological
conditions. So
for example, if you
refer to the chart
beforehand, you will
see that a lot of them
were accompanied with
uveitis or conjunctivitis,
which this picture
at the top shows
you anterior uveitis
on gross examination.
You can see that
there's injection of the
sclera, you can see
little keratotic
precipitates and then um
I don't know how to say
this but the um uh
the pus buildup in the
eye the ophthalmology
the ophthalmology um
residents would be
so disappointed in me
because I worked with
them for a month um
okay then uh for the
heart you want to listen
for any pericardial
rubs or um pericardial
fusions uh for the
lungs you want to
listen for any pleural
fusions and also So
some rheumatological
conditions can also be
associated with
interstitial lung disease
or scarring or
honeycombing of the lungs.
And then you want to
look at all of the
joints very thoroughly.
So that's looking
at all of the
joints that you can
see, the small joints,
the large joints.
And remember,
arthritis is defined
as intra
-articular swelling
of two or more
of the following
findings. So it
should be pain on
motion. Range
of motion is
limited. There's
warmth to the area.
And those would be
all signs that there's
arthritis or
inflammation going on.
At times, it presents
with limb length
discrepancy. And this
can be because there's
initial acceleration and
then there's destruction
of the joint, which
will then prevent
it from getting to
the full length. Okay.
All right. So basic
labs. So remember
that lymphopenia
is more specific
to lupus than
leukopenia. In systemic
GIA, which we'll
talk about GIA,
the white blood cell
count is actually
elevated, again, due
to the inflammation.
Platelets will be
elevated, again, acute
phase reactant due to
inflammation. Hemoglobin
is usually low, which
is nonspecific, but
usually due to anemia
of chronic disease.
Inflammatory markers,
including ESR
and CRP, will be
elevated. Remember,
they're nonspecific,
so it doesn't tell
you much about where
this inflammation
may be going on,
it just tells you
that there is
systemic inflammation.
CRP is more of your
acute phase reactant,
so that'll go up
faster, but it comes
down faster. ESR, it
takes a longer period
of time to kind of
build and then can
stay elevated for a
longer period of time.
Then rheumatoid
factor, which
I know you guys
learned about,
sometimes it's present
in children with
JIA and that is actually
a poor indicator
as well as a poor
sensitivity for
correlating with having
arthritis, but it
can be present in
less than 10% of
children. And there is
a specific subset of
JIA that is rheumatoid
factor positive.
If you correlate the
rheumatoid factor with
the symptoms, that
is a much stronger
prognostic indicator.
Like I told you, if they
have rheumatoid factors
positive, they have
bad symptoms of arthritis,
and you diagnose
them with JIA, they're
very likely that their
prognosis for developing
rheumatoid arthritis
in the future or
prolonged arthritis for
the rest of their
lives is very positive.
Okay, you could also
do the anti-CCP,
which is more
specific than the RF.
And so you'll get
positivity in the rheumatoid
factor positive
JIA subset as well.
You get the anti-CCP
will also be positive.
Remember that the
anti-nuclear antibody,
the ANA, has low
specificity. So what that
means is that in
30% of the general
population of normal
children, you'll actually
get a titer that is
1 to 60 for the ANA.
So and then once
it's positive, it
will reflect to all
of the other kind
of specific
autoantibodies, which
are listed in that
little area there.
But remember, it's
not recommended
for screening
purposes, but more
so for correlating
it with symptoms
that the patient
may be having.
Remember, your double
-stranded DNA, your
anti-Smith, those
can be associated
with lupus diagnosis.
Your anti-Roe, anti
-La, that's usually
Sjogren's or lupus.
Anti-histone gives
you the drug-induced
lupus suspicion.
And then the ANCAs,
the ANCAs are usually
for vasculitides,
anti-topoisomerase,
or SCL70, as
usually for
systemic sclerosis,
which is really
rare in childhood.
And then also if they're
having muscle weakness,
you want to check for the
muscle enzymes. So CK,
your liver enzymes,
so AST, ALT, and
then LDH, which
is, again, just a
breakdown. And then
aldolase as well.
for urine you want to
check for if there's
any protein in the
urine which could tell
you there's some
kidney injury you can
also do a protein
creatine ratio for example
in a patient with
lupus if they have
nephritis lupus nephritis
then they're going
to have a lot of
protein urea and that's
a good way to see
how bad their their
nephritis might be in
terms of imaging you
can do plain x-rays
for simple joints. You
can also do MRIs,
which is more sensitive
for early erosive
arthritis detection.
Sometimes won't show
up as prevalently in
plain x-rays, so MRIs
can be really useful.
Echoes, so if they
have any systemic
signs that is affecting
their heart, then
an echo will help,
especially with what
we talked about
with the pericardial
fusions and the
pericarditis, that can
also be seen. And
then PFTs, so if they
have any lung
dysfunction or, you know,
pleural fusions or
interstitial lung
disease, you can
see from pulmonary
function tests how
bad it is. And then CT
chest as well can also
help you determine
if there's any kind
kind of mediastinal
issue and things
like that. Okay.
That was a lot. Let's
go into pathologies
now. So JIA, juvenile
idiopathic arthritis
is the most common.
This is the one I want
you guys to focus on
because the most common
rheumatologic disease
in children, and
it's a clinical
diagnosis. There are some
supporting things
that can help you, but
mostly it's a clinical
diagnosis. So So remember,
these things that
are highlighted,
that's what I want you
guys to kind of focus
on. The age of onset
will be less than 16.
That is part of
the definition,
the criteria for
diagnosing it.
They have to have
either one joint or
more than one joint
affected by arthritis.
Remember what we define
that as. And then
the duration, super
important, has to be equal
to or greater than
six weeks of symptoms.
and that is sort of
the the three major
criteria and then from
there there's a lot of
different subtypes
of jia there's um
polyarthritis which which
tells you that there's
more than five or five
joints affected and
within the polyarthritis
that can be um
rheumatoid factor negative
or rheumatoid factor
positive cases of
polyarthritis you can have
oligoarthritis which
is anything less or
equal to four joints
involved. You can have
systemic onset JIA as
well. And that usually
presents with rash.
That usually presents
with the fever. Again,
that fever that goes,
you know, once every
day and specifically
spikes usually in the
evenings. So right
here, you see a chart
on the side and that
depicts the same thing,
how the temperature
shoots up. And I'm
sorry, I accidentally cut
out the x-axis, but
the temperature will
shoot up in the evenings
every day, so that's
what it's showing, and
then the other types
are psoriatic arthritis
and then encytitis
-related arthritis,
encytitis, encytitis.
okay so let's talk
about epidemiology so
jia has a wide ranging
number um of incidents
it really i mean it
really depends on
environmental
exposure immunogenetic
susceptibility
variations in diagnostic
criteria and then uh the
other problem is that
there's a lack of
population-based data
About 300,000
children in the U.S.
have arthritis.
That's estimated.
And oligoarthritis
is one of the most
common of those
subtype of the JAA.
The peak onset for
oligoarthritis is
usually between two
to four years old. For
polyarthritis, which
is another subtype
that we talked about,
it can be bimodal.
So this peaks in two
to four years of age
and then 10 to 14
years of age. And then
usually systemic
JIA usually happens
between one and five
years of age. There
is no *** predominance
for systemic JIA.
However, most other
subtypes are girls.
Girls are more
effective than boys,
except in the case
of endocytitis,
which is then more
common in boys.
The etiology is a
little bit complex as
well. Remember, we
talked about multiple
involvements, but
there's a complex
genetic trait, which
usually affects
both the humeral and
the cellular immunity,
MCH1 and 2, and then
also your protein
tyrosine phosphatase
non-receptor.
TNF-alpha is
involved, IL-6
is involved, IL
-1 is involved.
It's usually some
sort of a double
hit where you get
some sort of external
factor that triggers
the abnormalities
in your immune
system, which then
causes everything
to just go awry.
T cells are recruited
for non-self synovial
antigens, which then
cause that inflammation
cascade and then
add B cells and
complement all kinds
of inflammatory things.
um in the uh this
picture is a biopsy of
a synovial joint in
a 16 year old child
with oligo jia and you
can see the infiltration
of lymphocytes
which are i mean if
this was colored it
would be purple stained
and then also plasma
cells which are your
your mature b cells
making all the
antibodies so you can
see that they all kind of
aggregate in that
area and then cause
inflammation, and
destruction of the joint.
Okay,
these are all the
subtypes that there are.
Remember, we talked
about the oligoarticular,
which peaks between
one to three,
and it has more
female predominance.
It affects the knees
more than the ankles.
There can be some
uveitis present.
ANA will be positive
in 60% of populations,
and usually inflammatory
markers are normal
or slightly elevated,
but not terribly.
And then it also lists
the therapies. In
general, you can
remember the therapies as
things that calm down
inflammation, right?
So it's going to be
NSAIDs, but avoiding
aspirin, because aspirin
has its own problems
in kids. So NSAIDs,
like naproxen,
ibuprofen, those, and
then usually some sort of
a immunosuppressant
to calm down that that
autoimmunity that
they're experiencing.
Sometimes you can
bridge them with
steroids as well,
which can help
with acute
inflammatory instances.
Then it goes through
the polyarticular, the
two types, RF negative
and RF positive.
It goes through
psoriatic, which we talked
about a little bit,
which we'll touch on.
And then the systemic
one is last here,
where we talked about
it's a peak onset between
two to four. It's
equal incidence, males
and females. It's
usually polyarticular.
Often the knees,
wrists, and ankles are
affected. You can
have a daily fever,
which we talked about.
I have this rash,
pericarditis, pleuritis,
hepatosomatomegaly,
lymphadenopathy. For
your labs, it's going
to show you anemia.
It's going to show you
increased white count,
increased inflammatory
markers, ESR, CRP,
which goes along with
increased ferritin as
well, because that's also
an acute phase reactant,
which is also why
the platelets will
also be elevated. Okay.
And also for this,
the treatment is going
to be standing NSAIDs.
And then you can add
on systemic steroids
or IL-1 antagonists.
Okay.
Moving on.
Okay, so still
on JIA, the
joints affected,
so usually oligo
is going to be
larger joints,
polyarthritis is
usually going to be
both upper and lower
joints. Remember,
it can also affect
your TMJ, and
also cervical spine
can be involved,
and there could be
hips also involved.
And then we talked
about the treatment a
little bit. We talked
about the NSAIDs. We
talked about naproxen,
ibuprofen, meloxicam.
You can do DMARD,
so disease-modifying
drugs, specifically
methotrexate.
And this is given either
sub-Q, so subcutaneous
or PO, so by mouth.
And usually it's a
weekly methotrexate
administration. And
this is different than
when you guys learn
about neoplastics, when
we give methotrexate
for cancers, we usually
give it higher doses
and more frequently.
So, almost every day
or really high doses
of infusions of
methotrexate. And that's
a little bit different
than what we're doing
here. And when you use
methotrexate in a
lower dose and a weekly
dose, you're achieving
more immunosuppression
than you are doing,
you know, ablation.
You can also use
biologics like we talked
about a little
bit with anti-ILA
receptor antagonist
or anti-TNF-alpha
biologics. You can
also do intra-articular
corticosteroids, so
injecting corticosteroids
into synovium
directly. You can also
do systemic steroids,
but generally
we want to avoid
overusing them because
they do have side
effects like we know.
It usually is
very helpful in
bridging therapy
before sort of the
biologics and DMARDs
start working.
Okay, so this is
a picture at the
top with the
unilateral knee
arthritis going on
in a young infant.
Luckily, with the
steroids, when
they're on it for
about six weeks,
40 to 60% of patients get
better with
their symptoms.
Of course, we
want to make sure
that they're eating
something with
these NSAIDs, and
then also we're
monitoring their
kidney function.
And then the
methotrexate is really
great for avoiding
systemic steroids.
It's about 70%
effective, and usually
we'll give it with
some sort of a folic
acid supplementation,
like a one milligram
with it. And then
you guys will do
your research when
you do antineoplastics
about why we give
folic acid with it.
Uh, when the patients
are on methotrexate,
you do have to
check a CBC level to
make sure you're
not myelosuppressing
too much, which means
decreasing the cell
lines too much.
Um, and you should
also check LFTs because
the, uh, the liver
can be irritated by
methotrexate. Um,
the other pictures
I have are, um, the
one at the bottom
right here is a CT scan
of, uh, the TMJ
joint, the temporal
mandibular joint of
a child who has JIA.
And you can see the
degradation on the
right side, which
is uneven compared
to the left. Everyone
see that? Okay.
And then the last
picture I have for you
guys is a 13-year
-old with severe hip
disease. You can see
all this degradation
of the nice, smooth
-*** tabulum and the
femoral head that you
should be seeing. You
also see some joint
space narrowing right
here specifically.
It's really close
together. It's rubbing
together, and that's
going to cause a
lot of pain. You can
also get subluxation.
So this hip looks
like it's coming out
of the socket, right?
And this patient received
corticosteroids
systemically for about
nine years before
this got better.
Yeah.
Okay. So let's talk
about prognosis. The
goal is obviously
disease remission.
We talked about this
statistic already.
Oligo arthritis fares
better than polyarthritis
just because
there's less joints
involved. But it also
depends on how bad the
joints are affected,
if they have the things
that we talked about,
the complications
like subluxation, joint
space narrowing. um,
the earlier the age when
they present the, um,
the higher their, uh,
uh,
mortality and
morbidity become. Um,
and then, um,
also, but then it helps
because the sooner
you treat these
patients, the better
you can get them in
remission. Um, and
then if the patient
is RF seropositive,
that's also a poor
prognostic factor. Um,
if it involves the
hip wrist or hand,
generally that's also
a poorer prognosis.
Some complications, we
already talked about
this a little bit,
but the one thing I
will mention is the
uveitis is super important
because persistent
uncontrolled uveitis
can cause chronic
scarring and then
eventually blindness.
So, you can definitely
have ophthalmology
follow these patients and
they can do intraocular
steroids or even
drops that also
help with calming
down some of that
inflammation.
Um,
with joint
destruction, you're
going to have some,
you could have
some contract,
uh, contractions,
contractors,
sharks, sorry,
contractors. And
then also you can get
microognathia from the
destruction of the TMJ
joint area. Um, and then
leg length discrepancy,
which is what we
talked about when
there's destruction of
one side and not the
other. Um, this is an
example, this picture of,
uh, rash that could be
present in a systemic
JIA. It's erythematous,
it's macular, so
that means it's flat,
right? So it's red,
it's flat, and it
also kind of comes and
goes, especially during
periods of fever. It
can be more prominent,
and it can also show
on the trunk and
extremities, which is what
you're seeing here
okay okay so um for
classification uh and
naming the two main um
kind of schools government
government bodies
governing bodies are
the international league
of associations of
room classifications
which is your ILR and
then your American
College of Rheumatology
so the ILR is more
international use and
the American College of
Rheumatology is more
American study-based.
So as you can
see, JIA and JRA
are sort of used
depending upon
which class
you're going by.
And then the other
difference is that
the subtypes are a
little bit different.
The categories include
in the ILR one,
they include psoriatic
arthritis and the
anthocytitis-related
arthritis disease,
whereas they don't
include that in the
American College of
Rheumatology classification.
They also don't
include the ankylosing
spondylitis or the
inflammatory bowel
disease or things like
that, whereas that
is included in the
ILR classification.
So just things to
keep in mind and how
sometimes different
things are. But
the things that
they do agree on, of
course, is the age,
the duration, and
then, of course, the
systemic J aspects,
which are fever,
rash, and arthritis.
Okay.
Let's briefly talk about
anthocytitis-related
arthritis. The
classification criteria
are you have to have
arthritis plus anthocytitis.
I can't not saying
this for my life.
And remember, that's
just the inflammation of
the tendon that attaches
to these joints.
And these are the
anatomical areas
where you're more
likely to see ERA.
You can see that in
the sacroiliac joint,
and that can cause
inflammatory and pain,
inflammation and pain
in the lumbosacral
area. It usually has
presence of the HLA
-B27 gene. and then
usually this is an older
male like older than
six year old male
and you can have
accompanying uveitis is
very common usually
you'll also have one
family relative with
the HLA-B27 associated
disease in a first
degree relative remember
for diagnosis you
only need two of these
to be diagnosed with
ERA usually for six
months of disease
are asymmetric which
means that only one
side will be affected.
And then they'll
usually have less
than four joints
affected totally in
totality. So the
small joints of the
foot are highly
suggestive of ERA.
So classically,
you'll see it and
you can see it in
the skeleton as
well as this back
Achilles area, and
then also the
bottom of the foot.
Okay,
so these are the
spondyloarthritases.
There's a lot of
overlap, and I feel like
juvenile ankylosing
spondylitis is very
similar to ERA, so
that's also really
confusing, but we'll
try to do this together.
You also have your
juvenile psoriatic
arthritis, and then
your inflammatory
bowel disease, and
reactive arthritis is
also in this chart,
just for comparison.
As you can see, you get
peripheral arthritis
in all of four of
these categories. You
can have HLA-B27
positivity, more likely in
juvenile, ankylosing
spondylitis, reactive
arthritis, and then
also inflammatory bowel
disease. Your ANA
is probably going to
be more positive in the
psoriatic arthritis.
The axial arthritis
is basically of the
spine or sacroiliac
joints or hips arthritis
related. And that's
going to be most common
in juvenile ankylosing
spondylitis. But
you can also see that
a little bit of that
in psoriatic inflammatory
bowel disease,
but very less common
in reactive arthritis.
You can see anterior
uveitis in all of them,
in all of these diseases.
Skin manifestations
more commonly in
psoriatic arthritis.
GI, of course,
inflammatory bowel
disease, but also you
can see in reactive
arthritis as well.
And then inflammation
at the site of the
tendon, ligament,
joint capsule, the
anthocytitis that we just
talked about is going
to be more common in
in juvenile ankylosing
spondylitis and remember
in the classification
ira doesn't even
separate uh juvenile
ankylosing spondylitis
with um anthocytitis
so um that's something
to think about
because they are very
similar okay let's
talk about juvenile
ankylosing spondylitis
so usually um you'll
have a uh a male
that's older than six
years of age, you'll
have the uveitis,
you'll have the HLA-B27.
So you guys see the
overlap, there's
a lot of overlap.
And then 90% of
the children with
juvenile ankylosing
spondylitis will
have that HLA-B27.
So it's a very
strong indicator that
this could be
the etiology.
You'll get the sacroiliac
joint tenderness
and the inflammatory
lumbar sacral pain.
So in this picture
at the top, you can
see that this patient
isn't able to bend
all the way down. And
that's because the
lumbar sacral spine
has lost some mobility
from having ankylosing
spondylitis because
the lower spine
remains straight while
this patient was
trying to bend forward.
It frequently begins with
oligoarthritis
and enthesititis.
And then, again, the
criteria is called
Modified New York
Criteria, but you
need either both
of them or you have
either one of them with
two of the following
that we all just
listed. Again, the
family history also
can be important.
These are the character
six of inflammatory
back pain. So it
does not improve with
rest, improves with
exercise, which is the
opposite of musculoskeletal
pain. it's insidious
in the onset and it
has a good response
to NSAIDs. So treatment
will be to control
the inflammation,
preventing the ankylosis,
which is that fusion
of the bones, which
is what you see why
this patient cannot bend
forward, and that
you're going to do with
disease-modifying
drugs and also NSAIDs.
And then physical
therapy, of course, can
also help strengthen
those muscles and loosen
them so that the
patient can have better
range of motion. The
prognosis for this
disease is, so if the
disease has been ongoing
for more than five
years, then the
disability is very likely.
So you want to catch
it kind of earlier
and you want to treat
it earlier to have
these patients be in
remission and so that
they don't progress to
this kind of prognosis
where they've had it
for more than five
years. And now disability
is very common and
remission is only
possible in less than
20% of those patients.
All right, moving on.
Psoriatic arthritis.
So this one is
characterized as it's
unique is sort of the
skin findings, right?
Like we saw in the
chart. So you'll
see nail pitting or
oncololysis. And you
can also see dactylitis.
So these little
fingers will also be
swollen and arthritic,
which you can
see in B. So sausage
fingers of the toes.
And then also the
specifically these
two toes look a little
bit, sorry, these
toes look a little
bit more sausagey.
And then you see some
nail pitting in C.
And then in A, you see
that classic psoriatic
rash, which is
erythematous plaques with
a silver scale, which
is what you'll see.
Usually for
diagnosis, you need
both arthritis
plus psoriasis.
For the other way to
diagnose it, if you
have either psoriasis
or arthritis, then you
need two or more of
the following that we
talked about and this
disease really peaks
during preschool
and early
adolescent years
and this this was a
patient for a
nine-year-old with
with psoriatic
arthritis so okay let's
talk a little bit about
reactive arthritis
so you guys I know
learned this from a an
adult point of view
and you learned the
classic you know
phenomenon on, like can't
see, can't pee, can't
climb a tree. So
can't climb a tree,
you got arthritis, you
can't pee, you have
urinary complaints, and
then also can't see,
which you have the
uveitis. So this one
is usually defined
as joint inflammation
caused by sterile
inflammatory reaction
after a recent
infection three days
to six weeks prior.
Usually in kids, though,
those three things
that we talked about,
the mnemonic, is
not exactly applicable.
Usually, it's more
systemic signs like
fatigue you can get
rashes um so like
cutaneous manifestations
like erythematous
oral macules plaques
erosions erythema uh
erythema endodosum
fingertip erosions um
and enthesititis and then
the dactylitis as
well um arthritis is
usually asymmetric
so um and and you can
see a little bit of
the swelling of the
posterior aspect of the
heel it looks way worse
on the left than it
does on the right.
And then some of the
bacteria that can
cause these symptoms
or can cause reactive
arthritis is Salmonella,
Shigella, Yersinia,
Campylobacter, GU
infections with
chlamydia, E. coli, and
C. diff are a little
bit less common. The
E. coli and C. diff
are less common, but
GU infections like
chlamydia can definitely
trigger reactive
arthritis. Also,
some viruses like
adenovirus, CMV, EBV,
HSV, paravirus, and
rubella can also cause
reactive arthritis.
75% of these patients
will be HLA-B27
positive. The
treatment for this is
usually NSAIDs,
but again, if they
have an ongoing
chlamydia infection,
you're going to
treat the chlamydia.
So let's talk about
some mimicers, which
again, like I said in
the beginning, they
like testing you guys
on and they'll give
you a couple of things
that will separate
it. So acute rheumatic
fever, remember,
is usually caused by
untreated group A strep
infection. And usually
it's two to four
weeks after the strep
infection or epitigo
or things like that.
And you're going
to look up the Jones
criteria and all the
things that are included
in there. And that
in the question
stem will help you
differentiate because
again, that can also
present with migratory
polyarthritis or multiple
areas that are
affected by arthritis.
You also don't want
to miss Neisseria,
gynecoccal arthritis.
This can usually
present with rash,
fever, polyarticular
migratory arthritis.
And usually it's
in a ******** active
person. And the
treatment for this
would be ceftriaxone.
Remember, Lyme
arthritis, like we talked
about, it can be a late
manifestation months
or years after the Lyme
exposure. So people
won't really remember,
oh yeah, like years
ago, I got bit by a
tick. Sometimes they
might, they might, but
usually they won't.
And so getting
some titers can
also help with
that diagnosis.
And usually the
arthritis will be in the
knee. So it kind of
mimics oligo, articular J.
You can also get
pyogenic or septic
arthritis, which is acute
symptoms of inflamed
joint. Usually it
requires an aspiration
of the joint fluid,
which will show you
increased wide blood
cell count and neutrophil
predominance,
which are signs of
infection. So if they
give you a question stem,
they give you
arthritis, but they give
you the joint aspiration,
the studies, and
those are consistent
with infectious stuff
when you think about
septic arthritis.
And the treatment
for that would
be to drain the fluid and
also to treat
with antibiotics.
All right, let's
talk about pediatric
onset lupus. So compared
with adults, kids
have more severe
disease and widespread
organ involvement.
So when I was a
resident at Montefiore,
we had a couple
young females, adolescents
who were admitted
for lupus, um,
flares. And so I did
get to see some of
these patients. Um,
and it is really, it
is really sad, um,
kind of all the
multi-system effects
that they can
have. Uh, and
usually they involve
multi-system,
um, disciplinary, uh,
teams. So the renal
team is usually
involved, um, the, um,
the immunology
team slash allergy
team is involved.
Uh, if, uh, They have
any kind of cardiac
manifestation.
The CARDS team can
also be involved.
So compared with
adults, like we talked
about, in adolescence,
they're more likely to
present with the renal
failure or nephrotic
syndrome, which is
why there's another
reason. That's another
reason why kids have
more severe disease
that can have more
widespread organ involvement.
The prevalence of
SLE in children is
about 1 to 6 out of 100
,000 kids, and it's
highest among African,
Asian, Hispanic, Native
American descents.
Childhood lupus before
the age of 5 is very,
very, very rare, and
that could actually
clue you into an
immunodeficiency problem.
and then the median age
at diagnosis is going
to be about 11 to 12
years of age and about
20% of lupus patients
are diagnosed before
the age of 16 which
is why it's important
for pediatricians to
know what the signs and
symptoms are for lupus.
So the most common
presenting sign like we
talked about is fever,
fatigue, hematologic
abnormalities,
arthralgias, arthritis is
usually symmetric it can
be polyarthritis
including large and small
joints and then neuro
complications are
actually really difficult
in peds patients too
because that can present
with irritability
and hyperactivity kind
of anxiety depression
all those things that
we normally see in these
patients as well
so antiphospholipid
antibodies can be found
in about 66% of pediatric
SLE patients, which
again, remember, puts
you at more risk for
being more thrombotic.
And then the treatment
is hydroxychloroquine.
The etiology
is a little bit
unclear how it
works, but we have
found that it
works really well.
Avoiding sun
exposure. You can
also do steroids
for acute flares,
methotrexate, biologics.
And the prognosis
for five-year and
10-year survival
rates really depend
on how much money the
country has. So in
more well-resourced
communities, the
rates are 99 to 97% of
survival rates,
whereas in lower income
countries, that goes
to about 85 to 79%.
In the pictures
above, you see in the
Grap A.
Right here at the
bottom, right here,
you see that malar
rash that goes
across like a
butterfly rash, right?
You see a little
bit of vasculitis
in the toes.
You can see that
hard palate ulcer
and then the discoid
rash as well
that you can see.
Here is also another
example of the
skin manifestations
that you can
find. Remember, the
sun exposed areas
will be a little
bit more prominent.
um what else and
then the alopecia is
what we talked
about before as well
all right one cool
thing i want to talk
about is called neonatal
lupus and um this
is really interesting
because it's actually
not an autoimmune
disease of the newborn
but actually happens
because mom transfers
her immunoglobulins
through the placental
blood barrier so
remember IgG can cross
over because it's
small enough. And so if
mom has anti-Rho and
anti-Law antibodies,
they can actually
cross over
into the fetal
circulation.
Most moms, interestingly,
are asymptomatic
from these antibodies,
and about only 50
% will have a defined
lupus or Sjogren's
diagnosis. So in
babies, this presents
with a malar rash,
which you can see right
here in the bottom
picture. You could also
see dangerous things
like congenital heart
blocks, and that
can range anywhere
from type 1 to type 3
heart blocks. I hope
you guys can review
that from cardiology.
They can also have
cytopenias, so
affecting their red
blood cell count,
white blood cell
count, and platelets,
and then also
hepatitis from this.
The pathophage is really
interesting because
it's thought that the
Rho and Lott antigens,
which are on cardiac
cells, specifically
in the AV node, which
is what the anti
-Rho and anti-Lott
antibodies cross and then
attach to. So
that can cause
fibrosis of the
AV node and then
varying degrees
of the block.
Remember, AV node
is where most of
your heart blocks
will be transmitted
and how they
show up on EKG.
Um,
so this, um,
if the patient, if
the baby has complete
heart block, which
means that there's no,
uh, communication between
the SA node and the
AV node, then, um,
you're going to have,
uh, you're going
to need, um,
pacing, uh, because
again, your atria
and your ventricles
are not contracting
appropriately and
in coordination with
each other. So you can
have really inefficient
blood flow, you're
going to do, you
can give IVIG, which
has shown to be
occasionally helpful,
and then steroids.
If they have cardiomyopathy
associated with
it, it's usually a
really bad prognosis,
and they usually need
a heart transplant.
The data is really
mixed for using steroids
and IVIG to lower
the anti-Rho and LA,
and then sometimes
antibiotics can help
prevent, oh, sorry,
antibodies. Antibodies
can further help
prevent occurrence
in the future child,
which the prevalence
is about 15 to 20
percent. So you're
blocking the antibodies
from doing their
job using IVIG. So
the IVIG that you give
them will bind to
the anti-RAW and LAW,
preventing those
antibodies from
creating damage
in the baby.
In prenatally, you
can detect heart
abnormalities by
doing an echo.
And then it is
helpful to see the
P's cardiologist
prior to this.
The great thing about
this is because it
gets through mom, usually
you could just, you
know, wait for mom's
antibodies to kind of
wear off, which happens
about six months.
And then the baby
doesn't, would
not have any long
-term sequelae from
that unless they
have complete
heart block or signs
of heart block.
Sorry, the complete
heart block would be the
worst. So, and then
avoiding the sun. So
usually, remember, this
rash is going to get
worse with sun exposure.
So avoiding that.
Okay, let's quickly
run through the rest,
because these are
very similar to the
ones that you get in
adults. So juvenile
dermatomyositis. So
again, you get that
proximal muscle
weakness, distinctive
rashes of the faces,
extensive surfaces.
Here at the top
picture right here you
see the um the
groton uh groton
papules uh which are
the hypertrophic pale
red uh kind of
lesions um there's
about three cases
in about a million
children in the first
year um and then
the peak onset the peak
onset is usually at
seven years of age
females are more prevalent
than males and
there's some genetics
that is involved but
really is a combination
of genetics with
environmental factors um
children with uh with
juvenile dermatomyositis
either present with
rash or weakness or
both um and then
usually uh the uv light
exposure with generalized
erythema is very very
common um which is
seen in the shawl sign
the helotrope rash the
um the gattron papules
and then the mechanic
hands um which is
what you guys usually
see the helotrope rash
is the same one that
you can see in, um,
in adults. And then
remember that the
erythema crosses
the nasal labial
folds, which is
different than lupus.
Okay.
Um, a little bit
more. So usually the
weakness is systemic,
uh, muscles such as
neck flexors. Remember
proximal muscles
involved. So shoulder,
shoulder, uh,
hips, um, so combing
hair, climbing stairs,
getting out of bed,
this will all be
hard. Um, you can
get esophageal and
respiratory muscles
also being affected.
So sometimes if
you're worried about
that, a swallow
test can be helpful.
If you're worried
about the respiratory
muscles being weak,
then you have to make
sure they're not going
into hypercapnia,
which can then really
lead to hypoxia.
These people will
not show any work of
breathing, which is
really scary because
of their muscle
weakness. So you often
need an NIF, which is
a negative inspiratory
force machine,
which helps you kind
of keep those alveoli
open and can see how
bad your respiratory
drive is getting.
The EMG, which is
the muscle, electro
muscle, like the thing
where they put the
needles and then see
the muscle signals.
So basically, that
will show signs of
myopathy or weakness
of the muscles.
If you get histology
and you get a biopsy,
that's going to show
you inflammation,
necrosis. If you
get serological
testing, usually
it's ANA positive.
Sometimes you get
x-rays, you can see
calcifications,
which you can see
grossly, but also in
the x-rays itself.
um and then rf the
rheumatoid factor is
usually negative but
you will see um anemia
and usually your esr
which is long-term uh
inflammation will be
actually normal um
the treatment for this
is gonna be the same
thing steroids um
methotrexate sometimes
you can do ivig
usually the peas
rheumatologists are
managing this um but ptot
avoiding sun those are
all shown to be really
helpful um the mortality
is actually pretty
less like one percent
but really little
is known about long
-term consequences, but
they do respond really
well to therapy.
Okay, so
Bichette's disease,
this is a spectrum
of symptoms,
but remember,
it's vasculitis.
It's auto-inflammatory
in nature. It's about
10% of the adult
prevalence in kids, so not
very common. The mean
age for symptoms about
8 to 10, and there's
family history is
positive, usually about
20% of cases. um remember
the the ******* ulcers
that you get with
pitets usually those
healing kids with scars
uh whereas the old the
painful oral ulcers
don't don't usually
scar um anti-uve you've
anterior uveitis very
very common and then
erythema endosum or
that that calm um the
non-specific rash is
also very common so you
have to meet one of the
three criteria which
is what's listed on
the side um For eye
disease, we like to use
azathioprine, and then
we use topical treatments
for the ulcers.
Their mortality is
actually pretty low,
unless they get a
pulmonary aneurysm,
which can then increase
their mortality.
Sjogren's, really
quick. Again, it's the
parotid gland and the
eyes. You get dryness
of everything, so you
can get inflammation
of the parotid gland,
*********** of them.
very, very common in
Sjogren's. And that's
what kind of separates
it from all the
other things. You can
have symptoms like
systemic symptoms,
like fever, adenopathy.
You can get dental
caries a lot in kids
because of the result
of dry mouth. You
usually have to get
some sort of imaging of
the parotids and then
also biopsy, which
will show you
lymphocytic infiltration.
And so for this
clinical diagnosis, you
need about four of
the 12 items that
are listed here in
order to be classified
with having Sjogren's
disease. You'll
have an elevated
ESR, positive RF.
You can get increased
immunoglobulins,
and then you can
have SSA or SSB
antibodies that are
present, which are your
Roman laws. The
treatment is artificial
tears, massaging
the parotids, doing
lozenges and fluids,
steroids, NSAIDs,
hydrochloroquine,
so about the same.
um scleroderma can
be in two flavors so
systemic or localized
you guys know this it's
really rare in kids um
but mean age onset is
about seven to nine it's
more common in females
um there's only about
10 percent of kids
who have systemic most
most of the cases are
localized um and then
systemically you can
have pulmonary fibrosis
myocardial involvement
myopathy joint pain
all that stuff um and
then if it's localized
it'll just be limited
to the skin the sub-q
tissue These are all
signs right here of
crest and skin findings.
Okay, and the last
thing I want to talk
about is familial
Mediterranean fever.
This is an autosomal
recessive variant, and
specifically it's an
amino acid protein.
In Greek, that protein
is named for fever.
So usually this gene is
found in granulocytes,
monocytes, and
fibrolovas, and it can
cause autoinflammatory
disease. So this
occurs primarily in
Mediterranean ancestry,
Jewish, Turkish,
Armenian,
Arab, and
Italian patients.
It's characterized
by short recurrent
one through three
days of fever,
cirrhitis,
arthritis, and rash.
Most are present
with symptoms in the
childhood and about 90
% before the age of 20.
um again it sounds
exactly like all the
rheumatological conditions
right um but the
thing that differs
is that in between
these episodes of fever
rash arthritis you'll
have periods where
there's no symptoms
at all um and that can
help you as well to
think about it um and
then the frequency
of attacks really
depends so it can vary
from you know weekly
to one to two flares
per year. And usually
we do prophylactic
colchicine, depending
upon how bad the
flares are and the
severity and intensity of
the flares. This is
just the minor criteria
for diagnosis. And
then this is just the
erythema rash that
you can get with it.
Okay, in summary, I know
it's really confusing.
I know they all sound
the same. But what
I want you to take
away is sort of this
summary page. So JAA,
remember, that's the one
I want you guys SNL,
younger child, there's
so many different types.
Remember the systemic
type, okay? For
ankylosing spondylitis,
it's going to be a male.
It's going to be SI
joint pain. You're
going to have HLA-B27
positivity and restriction
in range of motion.
Psoriasis, you're
going to have the
nail pitting, the
findings of joint
pain and rash.
Reactive arthritis,
they're going to
give you some history
of having a
previous infection.
Uveitis, very common.
HLA-B27, very common.
For pediatric SLE, so
lupus, you're going
to have multi-organ
involvement and all your
complementar markers
will be decreased and
inflammatory markers
will be increased.
Vachette's has that nice
******* and oral ulcers,
uveitis, and remember
it's a vasculitis.
Juvenile dermatomyositis
has the rash and
the muscle weakness,
the proximal muscle
weakness, right?
Sjogren's will have the
parotiditis, and
then the eye dryness,
and then scleroderma
will have the
calcinosis and the
fibrosis, which
can either be
cutaneous or systemic.
Okay, so back to
our question. So
I'll give you a
second to read it
over, and then
we're going to talk
about what blood
work we would want,
or what blood
work we would see.
So this is the diagnosis,
the systemic JIA,
because remember you
have the penicillomegaly,
you have the
lymphadenopathy, you have
that daily fever and
the rash accompanied
with it. You're
fitting into the JIA
diagnosis because the
patient's less than 16.
It's been going on for
more than six weeks.
So that's all good.
And then your lab work
is going to show an
elevated white blood
cell count. It's going
to show inflammatory
markers are elevated.
It's also going
to show anemia, which
kind of says here
with the conjunctiva
being there. And then
you can have elevated
to normal platelets,
again, because that
acute phase reactant.
And we're going to
treat with NSAIDs,
so like naproxen, not
aspirin, naproxen.
And these are my
sources. I do recommend
watching Lecturio
Medical on YouTube. It's
for GIA. It's really
good. It's really
comprehensive. And
it's a quick kind of
overview of everything
if the lecture doesn't
fit with exactly how
you learn, right?
You should cater it
to how you learn best.
Please do the feedback
form. That's how
we know if we're
getting better. This
is your education.
So again, it's really
important for you
to fill out feedback
so we can try to
change it if it's
not working for you
or you have some
suggestions on how to
make it even better.
Okay, thank you
so much, guys.
I really appreciate
it. Thanks.